La ola de calor asola al viejo
continente un momento crítico en Francia
15 departamentos en alerta roja los
evacuados por los incendios forestales
superan ya los 16.000 en la región de
Girón al suroeste las llama recobraron
intensidad por lo que las autoridades
piden extremar las precauciones
vamos a tener una jornada que va a ser
complicada ligada a las temperaturas
pero también ligada al cambio de la
dirección del viento lo que significa
que ciertas zonas que hoy no se han
quemado durante el día o al menos al
final del día es probable que lo hagan
por su parte la comisión europea
prometió movilizar la asistencia
necesaria para paliar los efectos de
esta ola de calor a medida que surgen
más y más incendios forestales en toda
Europa la comisión europea sigue
trabajando incansablemente para
movilizar la ayuda quienes la necesitan
por supuesto seguimos vigilando la
situación durante esta ola de calor sin
precedentes y Seguiremos movilizando el
apoyo que sea necesario este lunes el
presidente del gobierno español visitó
algunas de las zonas más afectadas por
los incendios y se refirió al cambio
climático como el fenómeno que está
detrás de la catástrofe en España las
llamas ya dejan dos víctimas mortales
quisiera trasladar una evidencia Y es
que el cambio climático mata mata
personas como hemos visto mata también
nuestro nuestro ecosistema nuestra
biodiversidad y también destruye los
bienes más preciados del conjunto de la
sociedad que se ve afectada por estos
incendios sus casas sus hogares sus
negocios su ganado Reino Unido también
ha empezado la semana bajo la alerta de
temperaturas extremas para algunos ya es
momento de aprender a convivir con esta
nueva realidad
creo que el cambio climático está
definitivamente ocurriendo tenemos que
hacer algo al respecto pero aparte de
eso solo hay que aprender a vivir con
ellos
Europa vive su segunda ola de calor en
menos de un mes con temperatura
récord medidas de emergencia y un
balance trágico de víctimas